learning new details about a deadly
human trafficking tragedy in Texas at
least nine people are dead after being
packed into his sweltering
tractor-trailer it was found parked
outside of Walmart in San Antonio about
30 others are hospitalized officials say
more than a hundred people may have been
inside this trailer many suffered from
extreme dehydration and heatstroke some
of the victims are believed to have
entered the country illegally from
Guatemala and Mexico San Antonio is
about a hundred and fifty mile drive
from the border mark Strassmann is in
San Antonio where temperatures reached
more than a hundred degrees over the
weekend mark good morning good morning
in the back of this tractor-trailer
there was no air-conditioning there was
no water what there was at one point
according to investigators was more than
a hundred people stuck inside what
amounted to an oven on wheels inside
this tractor-trailer
police and emergency responders found
eight people already dead and dozens
more overheated and struggling to
survive paramedics and firefighters
found that each one of them have heart
rates over about 130 beats per minute
which again they were very hot to the
touch
overnight Sunday a Walmart employee was
approached by one of the victims asking
for water
the employee called 911 vestigators
believed more than 100 people rode the
trailer into San Antonio checking the
video from the
came in picked up a lot of folks over in
that trailer that survived the trip in a
statement US Attorney Richard Durbin
called it an alien smuggling venture
gone horribly wrong adding all were
victims of ruthless human smugglers
indifferent to the well-being of their
fragile cargo Homeland Security made
nearly 2,000 human smuggling arrests in
2016 that's up from the more than 1,400
human trafficking related arrests in
2015 it's hard to imagine the suffering
that went on inside of that truck
Jonathan Ryan is the executive director
of Rises an organization that provides
legal services for refugees and
immigrants this happens more than you
can realize because people are desperate
to flee other countries and come to this
country and they will take even extreme
measures such as this to find that
freedom investigators don't know how
long people were stuck in that truck the
driver was arrested 60 year-old James
Bradley of Clearwater Florida he'll be
arraigned on federal charges later this
morning the truck is registered to pile
transportation out of Iowa its owner has
not responded to our request for comment
Charlie mark thanks